heart attacks that's the number one
killer like this is the thing that most
people are gonna die from you aren't
Invincible no matter how fit you are I
mean I mean it's yeah it's real okay
just watch this
his name is Timothy O'Donnell and he is
a professional long course triathlete
with over 50 Podium finishes Timothy is
the 2009 itu long distance world
champion from the USA he plays second at
the 2019 IRONMAN World Championships in
Kona Timothy's impressive 20-year
athletic journey and more importantly
his life nearly came to a tragic end
when he suffered a Widowmaker heart
attack in the middle of a half Ironman
race you know I asked myself am I going
to die two children is Bill Finn and
Finn was only eight weeks old at that
one so cannot wait to give rainy and the
kids hugs gonna change my perspective on
life that's for sure